next up helper desk I thought it'd be
need to start a channel about a new
passion and update your progress as you
improve for example I love surfing yet
I've never been would watch me learn to
surf be a good idea yeah um I kind of
think again anything you know I am a
massive fan a couple of things one is
visual assessment success looks like and
actually is a great way to overcome your
to self-police and limitations because
if you visualize yourself being
successful you know actually changes
what's in your head and you believe all
um the other thing that kind of pretty
significant here is I think there's a
lot of things now of the word we live in
a global village and everything's
available to everybody and it's just
unimaginable the Internet's changed our
life so so things like kind of surfing
stuff like that and cool incredible
sports um around there so I think again
if there's a passion there's an idea I'd
encourage everybody to be disrupter to
innovate innovate innovate and create
something that's kind of very different
in terms of different experience so you
go for it you'll find out quickly if you
launch a business like that whether
there's a lot of interest of arms and
whether it's the right time yeah I mean
to add to that I would say as a general
principle in business if you provide
value to people you will make money
right you provide more value make more
money provide value quickly you'll make
money quickly it's about providing value
to somebody else and so you know if you
don't know how to surf then your value
won't be in providing expert surf tips
right because you're not the surfer yet
but I love the idea of taking people
along the journey with you because
you're approaching it from a beginner's
mind and they will learn as you learn
and for anybody who's started a new
project I'm a huge believer in increment
youtube channel or in allowing people to
follow you and what you're doing on
twitter or facebook and keep updating
them and as you make mistakes and as you
learn you create content about that i'm
writing my first book with with penguin
Random House I've never written a book
before and every week I make a video on
my youtube channel
my book writing process frustrations I
have winds that I'm having I answer your
questions and I'm bringing you along the
journey with me to help you understand
that book writing process I can't make a
book about uh sir I can't make a video
about here's the 10 things you need to
do to write a best-seller book because I
haven't done it yet but I can make those
videos about my journey and so I think I
think that's the value that you can add
as a kind of side twist to this a little
curveball I dad is I think making it
public and also keep you on track with
your business I think if you are
starting up any new thing it could be it
can be exciting but also frustrating and
lonely and you may go out and you start
surfing and you fall and you fail and
the guy that's it I'm done I'm never
going to be good at this but if you now
have a community of people supporting
you and cheering you on and you're
committed to them you're much more
likely to follow through just like when
you tell your friend hit come to the gym
with me you're going to go to take that
Jim appointment and so I think that the
side benefit could be it gives you a lot
more motivation as well to actually
execute against your plan in the Lotus
of your interview maestressa but
everybody's posting stuff on Facebook
Instagram and it sort of paints of
vision of the world that's perfect
everyone is a celebrity go to Vegas for
weekend spring break everybody's having
fun all the time and kind of that's not
real so what you bring out is people
genuine real life kind of all abilities
so if you're out there and learning to
surf you go to community and you share
your kind of hold abilities that's very
engaging and kind of brings people with
you and you know all the kind of face
book heroes out there there's ten brands
now a lot of it's based on just
connected with real life people with
real life situations physics foreign
people's vulnerabilities you write your
books that's tough every day's a perfect
day not every day comes out with the
best chapter so I kind of think this
you're onto something if I just
connecting with people for a lot of
emotions